welcome to this video super cheese yeah
super I had cheese but well it's not
playing ok now it is and let's see get
the NIMS Oh or the bogo or yep the news
oh ok let's go with this line at the
zurich variation know that I'm proof
reading my book kind of see see all the
lines again so it feel reasonably yeah
like I already know no other things if
you've written a book it's not
guaranteed that you can actually
remember all the lines that you let you
roll down it's really quite a lot b3 now
is the the normal reply here no I have
this okay that's not very very common
actually but check if I mean common this
may be the wrong word it's it's really
really unusual to play like that I
wonder if I have or should play b5 mb5
try to get to the d5 pawn what just see
6 which is also quite ok I believe let's
do that I'm not completely sure he
should take now efore is not helping him
in any way and yeah and now interesting
movement yeah i was thinking that night
a5 should actually be quite ok because
of the c-4 porn that I can
attack i'm going to try that ah maybe
you can go see five and maybe play c5
him just trading see against you pawn
now that's a possibility yeah I saw that
too late can I go you for however you
for sure maybe 95 then right I don't
know I don't know I don't know yeah i
played this I should have thought about
95 a little bit allowing the c5 is
strictly business Jim so let's see I
have to go III I guess yeah otherwise
this didn't make any sense so let's do
that okay do I have any really good
option here it's not easy probably group
the eight maybe something like that
I really hate that one light on a5 is
absolutely unprotected but maybe I can
play b6 at some point to make sure that
I'm not blundering it quickly yeah those
kind of moves there they can be very
embarrassing yeah b6 cannot be really
good I guess but what what else am queen
83 yards and looks terrible the worst
thing is he can actually castle which I
try to make a bit more difficult maybe I
can go here a queen a form also not good
okay I hate to do it ah what a bad
position 95 is any good probably not
nigeria I always have here here's even
even as Bishop defo so it's just a bad
position what can you do allowing this
if I've was really bad trying to just a
techie 3 which is very very wrong very
very simple chess an additional point
however is that sometimes I have Queen
h6 so if he is playing a move like let's
say Bishop d4 then Queen h6 might be
might be something nothing great
admittedly but taking h2 and III yeah we
actually get to that
okay so yeah I don't see if a big
drawback to it so let's play it and I
will tq3 next move you know he has Queen
to see seven which is really really
really annoying move Wow oh ok to call
that annoying assem this is really wow
that's almost just like losing almost
maybe rookie aid somehow look fa them
look afraid I have to play yeah anyway I
have to do that going back assume this
is absolutely no option Queen sister now
Wow yeah I can can maybe even play look
f7 now or something like that from the
look that looks terrible but maybe they
have matter no but what exactly is his
move it looks terrible but maybe it is
not not losing straight away wouldn't
surprise me the whoever it was ok well
you cannot take you three that such that
much is clear if it takes be 6 the
rookie saying maybe I'm not in a maybe
I'm not in trouble maybe I'm not in
trouble huh
curious I actually don't see a move for
him now funny yeah when I saw that but
this is not really helping him that much
can trade and take the look and then all
of a sudden just by magic I'm an
exchange up it's not an easy win but I
all means I still have some amazingly
badly placed pieces after night c4 I may
be Nancy for I have / should be six and
they must play the move I mean I cannot
think about much here
now I can go here Bishop c6 I can take
h3 check i'll be i'll take it should
take whatever I can get I should take em
this point is so ever dangerous without
any doubt not easy at all time morning
check
that's the jacket to check that's quite
nice wait resign well he totally fell
apart there after all play me I guess oh
yeah I mean I'm also a little bit he'll
play plow outplayed myself was but just
till he did a good job I think before I
don't really mind that much he is this
an interesting moment of course I mean I
have some normal moves but there are
also some interesting move that are
normally not available this is this is
one of them quite interesting the idea
is to if he takes to gain this bond
which is interesting just smashing away
the whole center would have been
interesting maybe be five but I got
attracted to this idea of it of course
what I didn't see before and is that
after Knight a5 c5 he sees just opening
up the position to his favor this is
probably also happening here this is not
really not really nice gym yeah that was
good and here I'm really in trouble I
mean if I was probably not helping much
but I wanted to do something but it's
it's it's simply not good yeah Oh Quincy
five here was interesting didn't see
that move at all attacking III and he
cannot defend it funny ha yeah this
cannot move and well I'm attacking here
I cannot defend it funny now I didn't
see that
here and now the comp suggest h4 I was
really fearing what he exactly what he
did but it seems that it's not that that
grade however what also is true if we
look at this this is not like brilliant
from me he's really active so after this
I mean look at my night yeah it's really
an unlucky piece I'm not quite sure what
you should play maybe here this is what
the comp suggests it's got b6 Dallas's
interesting why definitely has some has
some he's not just an exchange down for
porn he has a really playable position
him hard to tell maybe it's a it's it's
it's probably good enough for equality
at least remarkable yeah but it's
difficult yet already lost the thread
certainly yeah this is got a kind of
check see it here happily blunder to
this check however it seems that this
was a bad move check what is the comp
suggest in 93 with the quality it's a
funny funny way to put it really okay
the pawn is strong but I wouldn't have
expected it to just be black equal
Bishop c5 as a tricky move yeah yeah
that wasn't so clear or even after
winning the exchange okay well i hope
you enjoyed it thanks for watching